[Music]
there is no other artist quite like
hieronymus bosch
whilst davinci was finishing the mona
lisa and michelangelo was decorating the
sistine chapel this dutch painter was
conjuring up nightmarish hellscapes full
of grotesque and nonsensical creatures
but why did this artist create such
disturbing paintings are they the
product of a lively imagination or are
they the result of a troubled mind
afflicted by intense and frightening
hallucinations let's investigate the
paintings of hieronymus bosch and get a
glimpse of the artist behind his strange
and unsettling work
very little is known about the life of
hieronymus bosch even his portrait which
you can see now was made 30 years after
his death we do know that he was born
sometime during the mid-1400s and
probably spent most of his life in the
dutch town of setogrambos
he grew up in a time of deep religious
anxiety in late medieval christianity
ideas about sin death and the devil were
becoming more sophisticated and
descriptions of hell like in dante's
inferno were becoming more vivid there
was a genuine fear that demonic forces
lived amongst the population a fear that
led to the first european witch hunts
something that would only increase in
the coming centuries
this was the spiritual environment that
aeronaut bosch emerged from one where
devotion and fear were intertwined it is
clear to have affected him deeply as a
preoccupation with sin and punishment
pervade his work
let's start with his most well-known
painting the garden of earthly delights
it's a triptych with three panels
depicting three unusual scenes
the first on the left here is based on
the biblical story of adam and eve set
in the garden of eden we can see
familiar animals like elephants and
giraffes but just below them is a
freakish bipedal dog creature over here
a frog mouth bird eats a toad and
emerging out of this pool are hideous
multi-headed reptiles even in paradise
there is already a sense of discord
anticipating the horrors that lie ahead
the middle panel is a non-biblical scene
featuring hundreds of naked people
frolicking in a lush garden strange
organic structures dominate the
background giving an otherworldly feel
to it
the level of detail is astonishing but
highlights include people crawling into
this giant egg a multi-legged dancing
owl and finally a cute cat-like unicorn
the inhabitants of this panel seem to be
indulging in acts of lust and gluttony
two of the seven deadly sins
the last panel is a disturbing picture
of hell with all kinds of eccentric and
horrific punishments at the bottom we
have a pig dressed up in a nun's habit
it's attempting to get someone to sign a
pact with the devil this bird demon
consumes its helpless victims and then
defecates them into the cesspool below
over here we have a demonic choir master
leading a dirge crucifying a man on a
giant liar it also appears to be
tattooing music onto someone's backside
some have actually put this to music and
it sounds a bit like this
[Music]
dominating the center we have the
so-called tree man named after his
stumpy legs some believe that this face
is a self-portrait of the artist
there are so many interpretations to
this piece at large and all the little
scenes have their own theological
messages you could spend hours
deciphering even just one of them but
there's an idea that most people do
agree upon it's a warning against lust
and the pursuit of physical pleasure
the fear of sin death and punishment are
the subjects of many of bosch's
paintings this includes the last
judgment another triptych where he
illustrates the apocalyptic scenes from
the book of revelation there are lots of
non-biblical elements to this one like
small gnomes and a giant human bird
hybrid but believe it or not it's
actually not too far off the source
material as we've seen from another
video of mine the original biblical
texts include giant human-headed locusts
with scorpion stingers i guess bosch is
along the right lines
painting after painting bosch conjures
up horrific scenes each more nonsensical
than the last a trademark of his artwork
are the freakish creatures which can be
found in many of his surviving sketches
one of which includes the tree man seen
from earlier but where on earth did
heronous bosch get his inspiration from
there are many theories but a popular
one claims that he was suffering from
intense and frightening hallucinations
an idea which we can explore through
this next piece many of bosch's
paintings focus on saint anthony he was
a hermit monk that lived in the egyptian
desert during the 4th century according
to christian legend he was often
tormented by demons this painting the
temptation of saint anthony is
characteristically bosch it depicts the
trials this saint is rumored to have
endured featuring a plethora of monsters
including this floppy-eared ice-skating
chicken demon my personal favorite bosch
made two other paintings about saint
anthony more than any other saint this
detail could be of significance you see
there is a disease known as an antony's
fire you can contract it by eating a
poisonous black fungus called ergots
that grow on rye crops symptoms include
sores convulsions and a fierce burning
sensation in limbs and extremities but
another unusual effect of eating ergos
are the frightening and overpowering
hallucinations that can last for hours
at a time they are believed to be behind
the many dancing plagues recorded
throughout the middle ages whole towns
would unexplainably dance all day and
night with some dropping dead from
exhaustion in the mid 20th century it
was discovered that when ergots are
baked in an oven they transform into a
form of lysergic acid dithalamide also
known as lsd
some believe that bosch actually
suffered from saint anthony's fire and
may have based his paintings on his own
frightening hallucinations creating so
many paintings to sin anthony may have
been a form of devotional prayer done so
in the hopes that the saint would rid
him of his debilitating illness it's an
interesting theory but one that's also
very difficult to prove as mentioned
already we know practically nothing
about bosch's life so it's unknown
whether he actually suffered from this
disease the same goes for the arguments
that suggest bosch was simply insane
there just isn't any evidence to either
prove or disprove it
i think there's another explanation one
with a bit more evidence to back it up
hieronymus bosch was not the only artist
painting demons even michelangelo did a
painting of saint anthony where he's
being lifted up into the air by
grotesque monstrosities both artists
come from a much longer tradition the
weird world of medieval christian art
delving into illustrated bibles and
early animal encyclopedias reveals a
whole collection of strange and
frightening imagery horrific
descriptions of hell grotesque monsters
and demons galore all of which predate
bosch and his renaissance contemporaries
in the margins of many illuminated
manuscripts you can find all sorts of
bizarre monsters some of them share a
passing resemblance to bosch's work it's
possible likely even that he reproduced
these creatures in his own work this is
certainly the case with that giraffe as
seen earlier art historians believe that
he based it on an illustration found in
an early travel log comparing the two
and they share a striking resemblance
people were drawing hell and demons long
before hirono's bosch was but you could
say that he perfected it a true
renaissance artist he took the flat
illustrations of old and transformed
them by adding perspective and vivid
colour bringing them to life through his
ghoulish imagination
now of course not all of bosch's
paintings are demonic hellscapes as with
many painters of his time he made
artworks about the life of jesus or
things that he saw around him but even
in the more mundane topics you're never
too far away from spotting a beastie or
two it is unfortunate that we know next
to nothing about the life of hieronymus
bosch only a shadow of the man through
his paintings it was clear that he had a
dark and vivid imagination and the
matters of religion and morality clearly
occupied his mind after his death in
1516 the next generation of dutch
artists were clearly inspired by bosch's
work in the centuries to follow artists
began to see him as an early pioneer of
surrealism being one of the first to
draw directly from his imagination
hieronymus bosch's dark apocalyptic
visions continue to transfix all those
who gaze on his paintings and offer
bleak glimpses of what awaits us in the
afterlife
hey thanks for watching hieronymous bosh
is one of my favorite artists so i'm
thrilled to be able to make this video i
really hope you enjoyed it too if you
like this video and want to see more why
not subscribe a like and a comment also
go a really long way
anyway i look forward to seeing you next
time
goodbye
[Music]